The Incredible Hulk is one of Marvel's oldest
and most recognizable icons.
Created by comics legends Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and first appearing in 1962's Incredible
Hulk #1, the Green Goliath spawned hundreds
of comics, two live-action movies, a popular
live-action TV show, and multiple animated
series, films, and video games.
And most importantly — big foam hands that
make smashy sounds when you hit things with
them.
"I've got the power of the Hulk in my hands,
and I like it!"
With so much Hulk over so much media, it's
almost impossible for even the most hardcore
fans to keep up with all of the stories.
Here's the untold truth of the Incredible
Hulk.
Banner SMASH!
One of the strangest and most hilarious periods
of the Hulk's history was the reign of "Savage
Banner" which turned the most well-known Banner/Hulk
relationship on its head.
Toward the end of 1995's The Incredible Hulk
#425, longtime Hulk writer Peter David changed
things up.
After enjoying a few years in the Hulk's body
while retaining the intelligence of Bruce
Banner, the Hulk transformed back into Banner,
but gained the simple mentality of the Hulk.
For the first time in the history of the character,
anger became the Hulk's greatest weakness.
Previously, even after turning into the Hulk,
the hero's strength would continue to increase
as he got angry.
Now he struggled to stay calm during fights
with the likes of Thor and Man-Thing, so that
he wouldn't get angry and transform into the
utterly helpless Bruce Banner.
Bob Banner
There are a lot of differences between the
Incredible Hulk comic and the '70s live-action
TV show.
One of the first obvious differences is that
the Hulk's more human half in the show is
named David Banner rather than Bruce Banner.
"David?
David?
David come on."
Kenneth Johnson, who developed the Incredible
Hulk show, explained that he changed the name
because he didn't like the comic book tradition
of using alliteration when naming characters.
"And I was looking to break away from that
tradition so that people wouldn't be thinking
comic book in any way when they looked at
the show."
Regardless of the reason, Johnson isn't the
first person guilty of changing Bruce Banner's
first name.
That honor goes to Stan Lee.
Lee was writing a lot of comics in the early
and mid '60s and used alliterative names for
his characters, in part, to help him remember
all the names.
Unfortunately, in the case of the Hulk, this
led him to mistakenly referring to Bruce Banner
as "Bob" Banner.
His solution, announced in a few issues later
in Fantastic Four #28, was that the real full
name of the Hulk's more human alter-ego was
Doctor Robert Bruce Banner.
Hilariously, that wasn't Lee's only name slip-up,
which is why 1963's The Amazing Spider-Man
featured a few pages of some guy named Peter
Palmer.
Red Hulk's real origin
In 2008, Hulk was relaunched with the creative
team of Jeph Loeb and Ed McGuinness.
The pair introduced the world to the Red Hulk
– a malevolent, intelligent, and vicious
red-skinned version of the Hulk who seemed
like he might be even more powerful than the
original.
It took a couple of years, but in Hulk #23
it was revealed the Red Hulk was General Thaddeus
"Thunderbolt" Ross, the same army general
who'd hounded the original Hulk for years.
Believe it or not, Loeb wasn't the first writer
to think of a red Hulk.
Kenneth Johnson, who developed the '70s Incredible
Hulk show, thought a red Hulk made more sense
since it's the color most people associate
with anger.
"YAH!"
But Stan Lee was adamant that the green Hulk
was too iconic an image to be changed, so
they painted Lou Ferrigno green and Red Hulk
went back into hiding for another 30 years.
Many voices
While Lou Ferrigno voiced the Hulk for the
'90s Incredible Hulk cartoon and in most Marvel
Studios films featuring the Hulk, he wasn't
the Hulk's voice in The Incredible Hulk TV
show.
The one where he, you know, actually played
the Hulk.
The source of the '70s Incredible Hulk's grunts
and growls was Ted Cassidy, best known as
Lurch from The Addams Family.
Cassidy also read the narration that told
the story of David Banner in the beginning
of each episode.
"Dr. David Banner, physician, scientist, searching
for a way to tap into the hidden strengths
that all humans have."
After Cassidy passed away in 1979, Charles
Napier replaced him as the voice of The Incredible
Hulk.
Psychic senses
You might think the Hulk's abilities are limited
to the physical, but there's more to the big
green guy than just pounding on stuff.
Throughout his comics, the Hulk has shown
some strange, almost psychic abilities.
During one of the Hulk's first encounters
with Doctor Strange in Marvel Feature #1,
Strange learned that the Hulk could somehow
see and interact with Strange's astral form.
Peter David later made use of this ability,
hounding the Hulk with ghosts both literal
and metaphorical during his run on Incredible
Hulk.
On top of that, the Hulk has always instinctively
known how to return to the gamma bomb site
where he was created.
More than 100 issues later, this was explained
as being a kind of psychic energy summons
from the Maestro — a future version of the
Hulk who was defeated by being teleported
back in time to the gamma bomb blast.
But this doesn't explain the Hulk's other
geographic instincts, such as in Incredible
Hulk #33 when the Hulk is able to leap from
the coast of Wakanda and instinctively know
how to angle his jump in order to land on
a tiny atoll in the middle of the ocean.
War horse
Beyond his ongoing rivalry with Wolverine,
the Hulk doesn't have a lot of connections
with the X-Men.
So it would likely surprise even Wolverine
to know that the Hulk was briefly the herald
of one of their most powerful adversaries:
Apocalypse.
In Incredible Hulk #456, Apocalypse captured
the Hulk and transformed him into one of his
Four Horsemen — making the Hulk the first
non-mutant character to be a Horseman of Apocalypse.
Apocalypse's transformation included cybernetic
implants in the Hulk's brain, a big sword,
and a retractable metal whip.
The Hulk's added power allowed him to easily
dispatch with the twin threats of Juggernaut
and the Absorbing Man — either of which
would be a match for the Hulk on his own.
X-Men destruction
World War Hulk: X-Men wasn't the first clash
between the Hulk and Professor X's students,
but it was definitely one of the most savage.
The green giant fought one of the largest
gatherings of X-Men imaginable, and he took
them down.
All of them.
While Professor X was a member of the Illuminati
— a secret cabal of superheroes who were
the Hulk's targets during World War Hulk — the
Hulk traveled to Xavier's school to confront
him.
Rather than allow their mentor to be taken
prisoner, the X-Men fought back.
At first it was only a small squad, but soon
all the active X-Men were facing the vengeful
Hulk, including X-Factor and the Juggernaut.
The Hulk eventually relented, but not before
breaking both of Colossus' arms and liquefying
Wolverine's brain by punching him in the head
over and over again.
"Ah Hell, I don't suppose you have any interest
in talking this out."
Trolled by Hawkeye
Even though Hawkeye shot Bruce Banner in 2016's
Civil War 2, nobody would consider Hawkeye
and The Hulk to be rivals.
Still, if you look at the narrative history,
they do have kind of a weird relationship
with each other.
Specifically, Hawkeye's always gone out of
his way to be a jerk to the Hulk.
"'Cause you just made me angry?"
"Really?
Because from where I'm standing you look more
beat up than angry."
After Hawkeye rage-quit the Avengers, he came
upon the Hulk battling the villain Zzzax in
Incredible Hulk #166.
Hawkeye was so determined to show his former
teammates what he was made of that he followed
and pestered the Hulk all the way into the
pages of Defenders #7.
He annoyed the Hulk so much that the Defenders
initially attacked Hawkeye, thinking he was
a villain threatening the Hulk.
Then, when Hawkeye took over the Thunderbolts,
he needed a way to boost team morale.
Once again, he targeted the Hulk — just
because he thought it would help their image.
Four years later, in Avengers #74, Hawkeye
decided the best way to get his spot back
in the Avengers was to draw blood from one
of its founding members.
After Banner proved that he could calm down
She-Hulk by talking to her, Hawkeye went ahead
and shot Banner anyway to force him to Hulk
out.
Even though he had a good reason to shoot
Banner in Civil War 2, one thing is undeniable:
Hawkeye's a real jerk.
"What do you want?"
"What do I want?
I wanted pickles!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!